die sonne birgt ein bisher noch nicht
gelöstes rätsel und es ist bis zu 5,6
millionen grad celsius während die
sonnenoberfläche lediglich 5500 grad
celsius heiß ist kommen die
sonnenatmosphäre wie corona auf diese
unglaubliche temperatur und niemand
weiss warum
jetzt hat die nasa eine sonde deep
akasol apropos sonne geschickt um dieses
rätsel endlich zu lösen vielen dank an
unsere ersten mitglieder auf dem kanal
die gestern für dieses thema gestimmt
haben klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen und ihr alle habt ja hier
schon in der community abstimmung
gezeigt dass astronomie top thema ist
und dieses thema hier ist mit sicherheit
das spannendste was ich da im moment tut
die sonne wirkt nämlich ein geheimnis
und das ist wirklich ziemlich rätselhaft
entdeckt wurde ist vor knapp 150 jahren
da konnte nämlich die korona der sonne
zum ersten mal bei einer
sonnenfinsternis beobachtet werden
der mond hatte sich zwischen erde und
sonne geschoben dabei analysierten
forschungsdienst das spektrum des lichts
und stellten eine grüne spektrallinien
fest die zu keinem bekannten element
hier auf der erde passt sie nannten das
unbekannte element kolonie um weil es
sie es bisher nur in der korona der
sonne entdeckt hatten
was für ein irrtum denn wer sich das
periodensystem ansieht wird feststellen
dass es kein solches element gibt noch
viele jahrzehnte hielt sich diese these
bis zwei astrophysiker das rätsel dieser
spektrallinien lösten es handelt sich um
eisen ionen also eisenatome denen aber
elektronen fehlen insgesamt fehlen ihnen
13 der 26 elektronen ein extrem seltener
zustand der nur mit unmengen an energie
erreicht werden kann
schnell wurde klar die korona muss
heißer als eine million grad sein
doch das ist paradox wie kann es sein
dass die sonne selbst nur 5500 grad heiß
ist aber die atmosphäre drumherum rund 2
bis 500 mal heisser
das ist so als würde man sich von der
heizung entfernen und es würde immer
heißer werden wie kann das sein
niemand weiß es genau es gibt theorien
und vermutung aber niemand ist sich
wirklich sicher was da oben genau
passiert deshalb schickt die nasa jetzt
die packers solarprodukte sonne
und zwar so nah wie noch nie einen von
menschen gebautes gefährt der sonne war
mehr als 1400 grad muss die sonne dabei
aushalten bis zu 6,2 millionen kilometer
wird sie der sonne dabei nahe kommen und
damit durch die atmosphäre durch die
korona der sonne fliegen geschützt wird
sie dabei durch einen zwölf zentimeter
dicken carbon panzer mit diversen
messinstrumenten ausgestattet dringend
die sonne so in bisher unbekannte
sphären vor und wird tatsächlich für
absolut bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
sorgen denn dort wo sie unterwegs sein
wird war vorher noch nie irgendein
menschen gemacht das gerät und es ist
eine absolut unerforscht region
zitat die packers oder pop wird
geschichte schreiben aber sie hat auch
das potenzial das forschungsfeld der
solaren physik in eine ganz neue
richtung zu lenken das sagt einer der
beteiligten forscher nur rafi von
applied physics laboratory der johns
hopkins university noch einmal vielen
dank an unsere youtube mitglieder für
ihre sensationelle unterstützung wir
sind überwältigt und freuen uns sehr
dass er bei dieser brandneuen
möglichkeit dabei seid wenn ihr auch
mitglied im team pixum werden wollt und
monatlich ein weiteres exklusives video
und euren eigenen privaten livestream
nicht verpassen wollt dann klickt auf
den button unter diesem video dort
erfahrt ihr wie das funktioniert und
welche vorteile euch erwarten in den
nächsten wochen werden wir das angebot
noch etwas erweitern ansonsten freuen
wir uns natürlich auch wenn er uns als
unterstützung ein like oder einen
kommentar da last oder das video an
jemanden schickt der sich genauso für
die spannende welt der astronomie
interessiert wie ihr und wenn er kein
video zum thema astronomie und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht denn
die etwas unzuverlässige abo box hier
auf youtube und werdet sogar vorab über
neue videos von mir informiert einfach
hier drauf kriegen und am besten auch
meinen schwester cara klicks um social
media abonnieren dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die genau glocke vergessen und
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken rätsel der sonne gelöst da
geht es aber ein anderes geheimnis
das inzwischen gelüftet wurde bis dann
bleibt dran